[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 8 mars
une grande partie de ce journal consacré
à la journée internationale des droits
des femmes de nombreux événements sont
organisés sur le département nous serons
d'ailleurs en direct dans quelques
minutes du prisme à elancourt avec la
chargée de mission aux droits des femmes
et à l'égalité dans les yvelines
retour également dans ce journal sur la
mort d'un rhinocéros au parc de thoiry
l'animal a été abattu et sakon scié par
des braconniers
une première en europe mais une pratique
largement est tristement développer dans
le reste du monde vous le verrez et puis
emmanuel macron candidats en marche à la
présidentielle était en déplacement aux
mureaux dans les yvelines l'ancien
ministre de l'économie a notamment
visité à un groupe scolaire et évoqué la
réussite dans les banlieues direction
donc le prix smile en cours pour débuter
ce journal le théâtre accueille ce soir
une conférence débat autour notamment de
l'égalité hommes femmes
en ce mercredi 8 mars journée
internationale pour les droits des
femmes et pour évoquer le sujet nous
sommes en direct avec marielle savina
chargée de mission départementale aux
droits des femmes et à l'égalité
bonsoir bonsoir marielle savina c'est un
vaste débat une vaste problématique que
vous allez aborder avec d'autres
intervenante ce soir au prisme à
elancourt mais avec votre expérience
personnelle est votre rôle aussi au sein
du département est ce que c'est un sujet
selon vous sur lequel la société
française avance positivement
est ce que par exemple comme le confirme
une étude dévoilée par l'insee hier les
inégalités ton à se réduire en france
même si bien sûr il reste encore
beaucoup à faire et que tout et tout est
encore imparfait oui bien sûr je pense
que les inégalités soient en train de se
résorber en france mais il ya encore un
chemin à parcourir
je pense qu'il ya des nouveaux enjeux
aujourd'hui aussi encore à combattre et
puis également je pense que il ya encore
des domaines où l'égalité n'est pas
encore réel elles sont justement vous en
parliez des nouveaux enjeux par exemple
qui existent aujourd'hui en 2017 et qui
n'existait pas forcément il ya quinze ou
vingt ans alors je pense que sur sûre
aujourd'hui le rôle et la place des
femmes je pense qu'on voit notamment le
monde du travail a encore du mal à se
mobiliser
il ya encore des différences de salaires
assez notable temps dans le monde de
l'entreprise que dans la fonction
publique
donc je pense que le monde du travail a
encore du travail notamment sans jeu de
mots pour pour combattre ces inégalités
notamment les écarts de salaire contre 8
oui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en france
encore en 2017 une femme gagne en
moyenne 25% de moins qu'un homme
à compétences et à travail égal pourquoi
selon vous encore aujourd'hui en france
en 2010 est une fine une femme gagne
encore 25% de moins comment on peut
expliquer de tels de telles barrières
encore en 2017
alors je pense que si les facteurs de
c'est si le résultat de plusieurs
facteurs la question des écarts de
salaires vont jouer sur notamment les
métiers occupés aujourd'hui par des
femmes qui sont des métiers beaucoup
moins valorisés c'est également les
périodes de temps partiel s'est les
ruptures notamment de parcours également
dans les congés maternité par exemple
et puis après c'est d'évacuer des
facteurs qu'on n'explique pas et qui
font que encore aujourd'hui une femme
est moins payé qu'un homme très
rapidement une des questions est ce
qu'avec votre expérience personnelle
vous qui êtes confrontés qui rencontrait
souvent les plus jeunes est ce que vous
êtes optimiste pour l'avenir est ce que
vous sentez quand même les choses
bougent et auprès des plus jeunes
générations pour les nouvelles
générations oui en effet des progrès
sont notables bien évidemment je pense
que par contre il faut rester vigilant
la question de l'égalité s'apprend dès
le plus jeune âge
dès l'enfance que les stéréotypes
sexistes et sexuée persiste dans notre
société
et comme disait simone de beauvoir il
faut rester vigilante la vie durant
merci marielle savina d'être intervenu
en
direct dans ce journal à saint quentin
en yvelines le vélodrome nationale est
également mobilisés pour cette journée
internationale des droits des femmes
plusieurs animations 100% féminine sont
proposés jusqu'à 22h ce soir et
notamment des baptêmes sur piste ou
encore un atelier relooking et bien-être
plus d'informations sont à retrouver sur
le site internet du vélodrome vélodrome
tirer national.com je vous le disais en
début de journal toute la journée
différents rendez vous on perd lui aussi
de mettre à l'honneur les femmes dans
les yvelines la préfecture de versailles
organisé par exemple une matinée
culturel pour interroger la place des
femmes dans la création artistique
alors que seulement 1% des compositeurs
et 24% des auteurs ne sont pas des
hommes
écoutez à ce propos marianne assis là
l'une des intervenantes au micro de
patrick keil jacques de dixmude enfin
aussi longtemps dans sa place qu'un
homme aussi bien au milieu culturel
on a plein de choses à partager à des
fins qu'ils sont bourrés talent contre
les choses à partager aujourd'hui à
véhiculer et c'est un moment aujourd'hui
c'est un bon moment pour montrer
aujourd'hui pour présenter nos créations
vous présenter ce qu'on sait faire et ce
qu'on veut partager comme message dans
le milieu de la musique
les hommes aussi peut-être plus de
choses on peut être plus dedans les
femmes sont plus occupés à autre chose
en l'occurrence les enfants et ces
machins donc moi je me dis qu'on peut
peut-être aller les deux c'est faisable
et en gérant son temps et surtout en y
croyant parce que c'est une passion faut
y croire il faut s'imposer quoi qu'il en
soit donc pense que pour moi la femme a
tout autant sa place qu'un homme dans
les cultures et enfin aversa et le
centre du service national a organisé
cet après midi une rencontre entre trois
femmes engagées au sein de la
gendarmerie et de l'armée et 150 jeunes
le but promouvoir l'égalité homme-femme
et contrer les idées reçues qui colle
largement aux métiers de la défense
notamment sur cette question précise
écouter l'une des intervenantes au micro
cette fois ci deux victoires god dans
l'armée la quasi totalité des postes
sont ouverts aux femmes est encore
quelques exceptions qui sont peut-être
en train de changer
actuellement dans l'armée de l'air
toutes les spécialités sont ouvertes aux
femmes que ce soit du fusillé commando
au pilote de chasse qui était fermée
jusqu alors et
voile annoncé être une femme c'est peut
être ça a pas un handicap dans l'armée
bien au contraire on peut avoir besoin
de prouver un peu plus que certains
hommes mais une fois qu'on a fait nos
preuves après ses bons dans le reste de
l'actualité locale mais non sans lien à
montigny le bretonneux deux
entrepreneurs viennent de lancer des
sports théo un site internet dédié au
sport d'occasion où l'on peut acheter et
vendre du matériel de sport parmi les
deux gérantes on retrouve l'ancienne
championne de natation anne-sophie le
parent t on qui s'est lancé dans ce
projet pour sa reconversion
après sa belle carrière sportive le
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
deux victoires goda une reconversion
professionnelle 2.0 l'ancienne nageuse
anne-sophie le parenté ont ex
coéquipière de laure manaudou est
licencié au cercle des nageurs de
marseille vient de créer une place de
marché sur internet le site est dédié à
l'achat et à la vente de matériels et
d'équipements sportifs d'occasion une
idée longtemps mûri par l'ancien athlète
pourquoi pourquoi pas parce que je
trouve que déjà moi je voulais
entreprendre mais je voulais être
indépendante donc
donc voilà entreprendre et après je vois
le sport parce que j'ai toujours fait du
sport et que c'est quand même l'élément
je maîtrise le mieux et que je connais
mieux et avec tout le réseau que j'avais
je me suis dit ça serait dommage de ne
pas en profiter pour lancer son projet
là sportif de 40 ans qui habite arts au
concours a décidé de s'associer à son
ami de 33 ans paulino j'ai un projet né
à l'époque où les deux collaboratrices
travailler ensemble au conseil
départemental des yvelines
ça fait 4 4 ans qu'on travaille ensemble
donc voilà progressivement on a appris à
se connaître et puis on avait des on se
complétait bien dans nos compétences
on s'entendait bien donc donc on sait on
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré lancée au
mois de février dans la zone d'activités
promo paul à montigny le bretonneux
d'exporter au contient déjà plus de 3000
références d'ici la fin de l'année plus
de vingt mille produits seront
disponibles sur le site internet pour
booster le nombre de clics et des
partenariats avec des sportifs célèbres
sont à l'étude
nous vous en parlions déjà hier dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi des braconniers
ont abattu un rhinocéros au zoo de
thoiry ils ont également s'ils
s'accordent un délit qui est une
première en europe les équipes du parc
sont évidemment sous choc pour rappel
les rhinocéros sont des animaux menacés
d'extinction retour sur cette triste
actualité avec camille lambert
ils ne sont plus que deux dans leur
enclos dans la nuit du lundi 6 mars des
braconniers ont abattu vince quatre ans
l'un des rhinocéros du parc de thoiry
arriver en 2015
ce accord n'a été signé une macabre
découverte mardi par la soigneuse
principal aux alentours de 9h30 et elle
est arrivée à la maison dit rhino elle a
constaté que la porte avait été
fracturée qu'une autre porte à
l'intérieur de la maison avait été
fracturée et elle est retrouvée donc le
mal rhino vince mort dans son box
on part quand même du principe que les
animaux qui sont dans un parc zoologique
son protégé justement du braconnage
qu'on rencontre dans la nature donc là
c'est très très choquant un choc pour
l'équipe mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
parcs animaliers
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
événement se produit en europe
en afrique du sud le braconnage de
rhinocéros a connu une hausse
considérable ces dernières années en
2015 1175 rhinocéros blancs ont été tués
pour leurs cornes contre 13 en 2007 il
ya un mythe autour de la corne de rhino
qui est absolument pas fondées
scientifiquement mais il ya des
personnes qui croient que c'est
aphrodisiaques que c'est une cure contre
le cancer alors que enfin pas du tout
c'est comme de la kératine c'est comme
les cheveux c'est comme les ongles sur
le marché noir
un kilo de corne peut être vendu 50
mille euros le parc est équipé de
caméras de surveillance
selon sa directrice les individus
connaissait les lieux le domaine de
thouars et va porter plainte
une enquête est ouverte et pour être
complet sur ce sujet sachez que la
ministre de l'environnement ségolène
royal a décidé de saisir aujourd'hui le
procureur de la république de versailles
pour engager des poursuites judiciaires
ségolène royal demande aussi dans un
communiqué que l'ensemble des pays
européens interdisent le commerce de
cornes de rhinocéros comme c'est le cas
en france
en politique maintenant le candidat à la
présidentielle en marche
emmanuel macron était en déplacement
hier après-midi aux mureaux dans les
yvelines l'ancien conseiller de françois
hollande a visité un groupe scolaire
fruit de la rénovation urbaine
commentaire de wilfrid richy sur des
images divines première un déplacement
sur la réussite scolaire mais aussi sur
l'emploi présent aux mureaux en début de
semaine emmanuel macron est venu
s'adresser aux habitants des quartiers
populaires et pour leur redonner un peu
d'espoir le chantier est vaste plus de
cent cinquante mille jeunes quittent
chaque année l'école sans qualification
dans certains quartiers comme ici on a
un tout qui est bien plus élevé donc je
pense que l'une des batailles forte
qu'il faut mener tour l'égalité des
chances c'est d'arriver à réduire de
façon forte
cette discrimination là parmi les
propositions du candidat dans marche des
effectifs allégés dans les zones en
éducation prioritaire avec un maximum de
douze élèves par classe vous avez des
élèves dont les parents accumule les
difficultés économiques ou sociales dans
les parents parfois ne maîtrisent pas
bien le français et qui ont donc besoin
d'un plus grand encadrement pour bien
maîtriser la lecture l'écriture et le
calcul
autre mesure généralisée la lutte contre
les discriminations ou encore accompagné
l'emploi dans les quartiers avec les
allègements de charge allant jusqu'à
quinze mille euros
les jeunes aussi pu entendre cet après
midi me l'ont confirmé
lorsqu'on veut réussir au sortir du
quartier il faut devenir footballeur
acteur de cinéma au comique maintenant
il faut pouvoir devenir professeur
d'université
entrepreneurs cadres supérieurs reste à
convaincre les électeurs de ces
quartiers populaires dans cette ville
des mureaux l'abstention atteignait 31 %
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2012 contre 20%
seulement au niveau national
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal rendez
vous demain jeudi aux horaires habituels
pour une nouvelle édition d'ici là tous
nos reportages sont à retrouver sur tv
fil 78 points comme ou l'application tv
fils bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]